I think we have a decent idea of how
signal is transmitted a longer neuron we
saw that you know a couple of dendrites
maybe that one and that one and that one
might get excited or triggered and when
we say it gets triggered we're saying
that some type of channel gets open
that's probably the trigger that channel
allows ions to be released into the cell
or actually there's situations where
ions can be released out of the cell
would be inhibitory but let's take the
case where ions are released into the
cells in an electro tonic fashion
it changes the charge or the voltage
gradient across the membrane and if the
combined effects of the change in the
voltage gradient is just enough at the
axon hillock to meet that threshold then
the sodium channels over here will open
up so sodium floods in and then you know
we have the situation where because the
chart the voltage becomes very positive
potassium channels open up to change
things again but by the time we went
very positive then that electro
tonically affects the next the next
sodium pump and then we have this
situation where that will allow sodium
ions to flood in and then the signal
keeps getting transmitted now the next
natural question is what happens at the
neuron to neuron junctions we said that
we said that this dendrite gets
triggered or gets excited and in most
cases it's getting triggered or excited
by another neuron it could be something
else and over here when this axon fires
it should be exciting another either
another cell it could be a muscle cell
or in probably most cases of the human
body it's exciting it's exciting another
neuron and so how does it do that so
this this is the terminal end of the
axon there could be the dendrite of
another neuron right here so this is
another neuron right there
I'm not drawing it that well but I think
you get the other idea this is another
neuron with its own acts on its own cell
and so this would trigger the dendrite
right there so the question is how does
that happen how does the signal go from
one neurons axon to the next neurons
dendrite it actually always doesn't have
to go from axon to dendrite but that's
the most typical you could actually go
from axon to axon dendrite to dendrite
axon to soma but let's just focus on
axon to dendrite because that's the most
traditional way that neurons transmit
information from one to the other so
let's zoom in let's zoom in right here
this little box right there let's zoom
in at the base the terminal end of this
axon and let's and then let's zoom in on
this whole area and then we'll also zoom
in we're also going to get the dendrite
of this next neuron and I'm going to
rotate it actually I don't even have to
rotate it so to do that let me draw the
terminal end so let's say the terminal
end looks something like this I've
zoomed in big-time it looks something
like that this is the terminal end of
the neuron this is inside this inside
the neuron and then the next dendrite
let me draw it right here
the next dendrite the dendrite of the
next neuron we put it right there so
we've really zoomed in so this is
dendrite dendrite of next neuron this is
inside the first neuron so we have this
action potential that keeps traveling
along eventually you know for maybe
right over here and if you can zoom in
which would be over here the action
potential makes the electrical potential
or the the voltage potential across this
membrane just positive enough to trigger
this sodium this sodium channel so then
this so did so I'm I'm really you know
maybe I'm getting really actually maybe
I'm really close this channel is this
one right here so then it allows a flood
of sodium to enter the cell it allows a
flood of sodium and then the whole thing
happens you have potassium that can then
take it out but by the time this comes
in this positive charge it can truck it
can trigger another channel and it could
trigger another sodium channel if
there's other sodium channels further
down but near the end of the axon there
are actually calcium channels calcium
channels I'll do that in pink so this is
a calcium channel this is a calcium
channel that is traditionally closed so
this is a calcium ion channel cow
GM has a +2 charge calcium ion channel
it tends to be closed but it's also
voltage-gated when when the voltage gets
high enough it's very similar to a
sodium gated or a sodium voltage-gated
channel is that if if it comes positive
enough near the gate it will open up and
when it opens up it allows calcium ions
to flood into the cell so the calcium
ions there positive to charge to flood
into the cells now you're saying hey Sal
why are calcium ions flooding into the
cells these have positive charge I just
thought you said that the cell was
becoming positive because of all of the
sodium flowing in why would this calcium
want to flow in and the reason why it
wants to flow in is because the cell
also just like it it pumps out sodium
and pumps in potassium the cell also has
calcium ion pumps and the mechanism is
nearly identical to what I showed you on
the sodium potassium pump but it just
deals with calcium so you literally have
these proteins that are sitting across
the membrane you know this is a
phospholipid layer membrane so maybe I
should just draw it maybe I'll draw two
layers here just so you realize that
it's a bilayer membrane let me draw it
like that it makes it look a little bit
more realistic although the whole thing
is not very realistic and this is also
going to be by lipid membrane get the
idea but let me just do it just to make
the point clear so there are also these
calcium ion pumps that are there are
also subsets of ATP ASE's which they
really did just like the sodium
potassium pump you give them one ATP one
ATP and a calcium will bond someplace
else a calcium will bond someplace else
and it will it'll pull apart the
phosphate from the ATP and that'll be
enough energy to change the confirmation
of this protein and it'll push the
calcium out or essentially it what was
the the calcium will bond and then it'll
open up so the calcium can only exit the
cell so that's what the it's just like
the sodium potassium pumps but just it's
good to know then the resting state you
have a high concentration of calcium
ions
here it's all driven by ATP a much
higher concentration on the outside then
you have on the inside it's driven by
those ion pumps so once you have this
action potential instead of triggering
another sodium gate it starts triggering
calcium gates and these calcium ions
flood into the terminal end of this axon
now these these calcium ions they bond
to other proteins and before I go to
those other proteins we have to keep in
mind what's going on near this Junction
right here and I've used the word
synapse already actually maybe I haven't
the place where these two where this
axon is meaning with this dendrite this
is the synapse this is the synapse this
is the synapse or you can kind of view
it as that the touching point or the
communication point or the connection
point and this neuron right here this is
called the presynaptic neuron let me
write that down it's good to have a
little terminology under our belt pre
synaptic presynaptic neuron this is the
postsynaptic neuron post synaptic neuron
and the space between the two neurons
between this axon and this dendrite this
is called the synaptic cleft synaptic
cleft I'll just write it as ass in
synaptic cleft and it's a really small
space in the terms of so what we're
going to deal with in this video is a
chemical synapse in general when people
talk about synapses they're talking
about chemical synapses there are also
are electrical synapses but I won't go
into detail on those this is kind of the
one the most traditional one that people
talk about so your synaptic cleft and
can in chemical synapses is about 20
nanometers which is really small if you
think about the average the average
width of a cell is about well depending
on your view at 10 to 100 microns that's
10 a micron is 10 to the minus 6 this is
20 times 10 to the minus 9 meter
so this is a very small distance and it
makes sense because look how big the
cells look next to this small distance
so it's a very small distance and you
have on this on this the the the
presynaptic neuron near the terminal end
you have these vesicles remember what
vesicles were these are just membrane
background these are just membrane brown
things inside of the cell so you have
these vesicles they also have their
phospho by lipids by lipid layers the
little membrane so you have these
vesicles so these are just you can kind
of view them as containers I'll just
draw I'll draw one more I'll draw one
more just like that and they can train
near these molecules called
neurotransmitters and I'll draw the
neurotransmitters in orem all that I
already use that I'll do it in green so
they have these molecules called
neurotransmitters in them you've
probably heard the word before in fact a
lot of a lot of drugs that you know
people use for depression or or other
other things related to our mental state
they they they affect neurotransmitters
and I won't go into detail there but
they contain these neurotransmitters and
when the calcium gets the calcium
channels they are voltage-gated when it
comes a little more positive they open
calcium floods in and what the calcium
does is it bonds to these proteins that
have docked these vesicles so these
little vesicles they're docked to the
synaptic they're docked to the
presynaptic membrane or to this axon
terminal membrane right there and these
proteins are actually called snare
proteins it's an acronym but it's also a
good word because they've literally
snared the vesicles to this membrane so
that's what these proteins are and when
these calcium ions flood in they bond to
these proteins they attach to these
proteins and they change the
conformation of the proteins just enough
that these proteins bring these vesicles
closer to the membrane they bring these
vesicles closer to the membrane and also
kind of pull apart the two membranes so
that the membranes merge let me
zoom in of that just to make it clear
what's going on so after they've bonded
with this is kind of before the calcium
comes in bonds to those snare proteins
then the snare protein will bring the
vesicle ultra close to the presynaptic
membrane so that's the vesicle and then
the presynaptic membrane will look like
this the presynaptic membrane will look
like this and then you have your snare
proteins and I'm not obviously drawing
it exactly how it looks in the cell but
it'll give you the idea of what's going
on your snare proteins have pulled have
essentially pulled the things together
and have pulled them apart so that these
two membranes merge and then the main
side effect the reason why all of this
is happening is this allows those
neurotransmitters to be dumped into the
synaptic cleft
so those things that those
neurotransmitters that were inside of
our vesicle then get dumped into the
synaptic cleft so they get dumped into
the synaptic cleft this process right
here is called exocytosis it's exiting
the the cytoplasm you could say of the
the presynaptic neuron but these
neurotransmitters and you've probably
heard the specific names of many of
these sirata nin dopamine epinephrine
which is also adrenaline but that's also
a hormone but it also acts as a
neurotransmitter norepinephrine also a
both a hormone and a neurotransmitter so
these are things that words that you've
probably heard before but anyway these
enter into the synaptic cleft and then
they bond they bond to parts they bond
on the surface of the membrane of the
postsynaptic neuron or this dendrite so
they'll bond let's say they bond I was
doing yellow so let's say they bond here
they bond here and they bond here so
they bond on special proteins on this
membrane surface but the main effect of
that is that it that will trigger ion
channels so let's say that this neuron
is is exciting this dendrite so when
when these neurotransmitters bond on
this membrane
maybe sodium channels open up so maybe
that will cause a sodium channel
to open up so instead of being
voltage-gated its neurotransmitter gated
so this will cause a sodium channel to
open up and then sodium will flow in and
then just like we said before that's the
quit you know if we go to the original
one that's like this getting excited
will become a little bit positive and
then if it's enough positive it'll
electro tonically increase the potential
at this point on the axon hillock and
then we'll have another we'll have
another neuron in this case this neuron
being stimulated so that's essentially
how it's happens it actually could be
inhibitory you could imagine if if if
this instead of instead of triggering a
sodium ion channel if it triggered a
patek if it triggered a potassium ion
channel if it triggered a potassium ion
channel potassium ions gradient
concentration gradient will make it want
to go outside of the cell so positive
things are going to leave the cell if
it's potassium remember I used triangles
for potassium and so if positive things
leave the cell then the if you go
further down the neuron it'll become
less positive and so it'll be even
harder for things to for the action
potential to start up because it'll hat
it'll need even more positive someplace
else to make the threshold gradient I
hope I'm not confusing when I say that
so this connection the way I first
described it it's exciting when this guy
gets excited from an action potential
calcium floods in it makes these
vesicles dump their their contents into
the synaptic cleft and then that will
make other sodium gates open up
maybe sodium gates and then that will
stimulate this neuron but if it makes
potassium gates open up then it will
inhibit it and that's how frankly these
synapses work and there's there's you
now have about to say there's millions
of synopses no but that being correct
there's trillions of synapses the best
estimate of the number of synapses in
our cerebral cortex is 100 to 500
trillion trillion synapses synapses just
in the in the cerebral cortex and the
reason why we can have so many is that
one neuron can actually form many many
many many synapses I mean you can
imagine if this original drawing a cell
you might have a synapse here synapse
here synapse there you
could have hundreds or thousands of
synapse even into one neuron or going
out of one neuron this might be a
synapse with one neuron another one and
another one another one so you have many
many many many many connections and so
synapses are really what give us the
complexity of you know what would
probably make us tick in terms of our
human mind and all of that but anyway
hopefully found this useful